[Music]
i teach middle school band cody go for
it
today started out as the best day of my
life
yes you know what that's going to say
joe
gardner i did it i got the gig
what the what is this place
[Music]
let's learn english with the newest
disney pixar hit film
soul and if you're new here every week
we make fun lessons with your favorite
movies
series music and so much more so that
you can learn to understand
fast speaking natives without getting
lost without missing the jokes and
without
subtitles just like astrid who says that
our lessons are helping her to master
american pronunciation
so we'll help you to achieve your
learning english goals too
it's really simple just hit that
subscribe button and the bell below
to join us so in the falling clip from
seoul
joe receives some news watch it and then
answer in the comments
how would you explain his reaction to
that news
i play this jazz teacher who's sort of
stuck
uh happily stuck but still stuck in a
job where he's teaching jazz which is a
sort of a throwback of a trade
when it comes to musical trade he's
teaching jazz to his to his little
you know his little kids in in school
i'll be right back practice your scales
sorry to interrupt mr gardner you're
doing my ears a favor
hey not you though you're good he's not
what can i do for you principal arroyo i
wanted to deliver the good news
personally
no more part-time for you you're now our
full-time band teacher
job security medical insurance pension
wow that's uh great welcome to the ms-70
family joe
permanently thanks
but joe has always dreamed of being
something else
in his heart he's a musician at heart
and since he was very young
joe always wanted to be a professional
jazz musician you could say that
jazz music is the dream that joe's been
pursuing on nights and weekends his
entire adult life
i play this jazz teacher who's sort of
stuck
when you say you're stuck you're unable
to escape from a bad or
boring situation your mom let you get a
tattoo
it's not a tattoo it's a birthmark okay
i've been stuck with you since birth
and that was never there before because
it was
then i realized we had done this same
silly charade our entire lives
i tried to get my mind off how i was
feeling
but i just felt stuck
joe the character that jamie foxx plays
has big dreams
however he feels stuck because he's
unable to make progress towards that
dream
in which of these three clips is the
word stuck used literally
meaning unable to move i've been stuck
in that job for eons
i needed a change huh you're stuck
stuck not what
nah this is when i'm yeah i'm stuck
mcqueen's probability of winning is
1.2 percent wow numbers
never lie i mean i knew his career was
stuck in them
yeah i'm stuck help him uh happily stuck
but still stuck
in a job where he's teaching jazz which
is a
sort of a throwback of a trade
when it comes to musical trade jazz is a
throwback
music genre because you associate it
with the past
this is true of jazz and you could say
blues as well
here's an example her whole outfit was a
throwback to the 1970s
if you use instagram you'd probably be
familiar with throwback thursday
which is a day that people commonly
upload old pictures of themselves
back to jaime he refers to jazz as a
trade what do you think that means
a job a music genre an item of clothing
[Music]
if you chose a you're right however
trade is not an exact synonym of job
in a general way a trade is a particular
business or industry
it also refers to the skills a person
needs to do a particular job
see here how joey from friends teaches
tricks of the acting trade
okay some tricks of the trade let's say
i want to convey that i've uh just done
something evil
well that would be your basic i've got a
fish hook in my eyebrow and i like it
i'll be right back practice your scales
we say this or be right back for short
to announce that we're leaving a place
for a short period of time
totally yeah this is incredible
i'll be right back sorry to interrupt mr
gardner you're doing my ears a favor
what he means by
you're doing my ears a favor is that his
students are playing music
so badly that he is relieved to take a
break from hearing them
let's now take a look at the connected
speech in this sentence
what can i do for you principal arroyo i
wanted to deliver the good news
personally
first this is one single word chunk what
can i do for you
what can i do for you but if you first
divide it into two
you'd first say what can i what is said
with a stop t
what not a true t what
can is reduced to in do for you
for is also reduced this is the whole
sentence with
ipa symbols what can i do for you
what can i do for you no more part-time
for you
you're now our full-time van teacher
if your job is part-time it means that
you work for only a
part of the usual working day in this
clip joe is a substitute teacher
meaning he's stepping in for the regular
teacher who at the moment isn't
available
because of an illness or other reasons
on the other hand
a full-time job is one in which you
spend most of your available time doing
usually considered 40 hours a week but
joe
has always dreamed of being something
else
let's analyze the pronunciation of this
sentence he barely emits the t
in but he says but joe
note the clear z sound in has and
always but joe has always dreamed of
being something else
normally when you see the letter s in a
final position after a vowel sound
it is pronounced as z in dreamed of
being
there's a link between the last d in
dream and of
dreamed of being but joe has
always dreamed of being something else
but joe has
by the way we've seen a couple examples
already in this lesson
of fast native speech now do you get
frustrated when you speak like this
and you can't understand if you're like
most learners that i know
i'm sure that your answer was an
emphatic yes
well i'm here to tell you that it does
not have to be frustrating
that's exactly why we created our master
class to help
you master the three keys to
understanding natives
at any speed which are vocabulary
pronunciation and cultural context
it's absolutely free so i highly
recommend that you give it a try
so that you can take a step closer to
reaching your dreams
of understanding english as well as you
understand your native language
just go up here or down the description
below to get started
in his heart he's he's a musician at
heart and since he was very young joe
always wanted to be a professional jazz
musician
we say at heart to describe someone's
basic character sometimes as opposed to
what one is currently doing or
pretends to be example he's a
businessman
at heart he says this to mean that even
though
joe's day job is being a teacher his
real passion is being a musician
more specifically a pianist jazz music
is the dream that joe's been pursuing on
nights and weekends his entire adult
life
to pursue a dream is a way of saying
that you're working hard to make your
dreams come true
we also commonly say to go after a dream
or
to chase a dream when or when will you
quit police work and pursue your dream
of poetry
because it takes a lot of work to
achieve your dreams there's always the
idea that they are elusive
so that's why we use these words that in
their literal sense mean to try to catch
a person or an animal
[Music]
hello how you been mr g uh it's curly
lamont lamont baker hey curly hey good
to hear your voice man uh yeah listen
uh you can call me joe now curly i'm not
your teacher anymore oh okay mr gardner
hey look i'm the new drummer in the
dorothy williams quartet
and we're kicking off our tour with the
show at the half note tonight dorothea
williams are you kidding me are you
kidding me congratulations man
wow i would die a happy man
if i could perform with dorothea
williams oh well
this could be a lucky day
[Music]
there's this big gig that's coming up uh
and he wants to go play for it he
finally goes and auditions and
uh he gets lost and for musicians or
anybody out there when you get lost in
your craft he's just in his thing
auditioning
no nerves he just went and they said wow
you're great you will have the gig
and then has a accident that causes his
soul to
leave his body and almost go to the
great beyond
and so he is trying to get back into his
body and back to his life
[Music]
hello how you been mr g uh it's curly
this question is also interesting as an
expression a lot of students ask me
what's the difference between
how are you and how have you been when
you ask
how have you been you're casually asking
how life has been for that person
since the last time you saw him or her
also
nato's often reduced this to have you
been
have you been i'm doing all right
i tried fencing today hey emily what
have you guys been up to
oh we went to see a collection of
victorian doorknobs at the cooper hewitt
museum
how are you is simply used to ask about
a person's state or feeling in the
present moment
hey look i'm the new drummer in the
dorothy williams quartet
and we're kicking off our tour with the
show at the half note tonight dorothea
williams are you kidding me are you
kidding me congratulations man
the phrasal verb to kick something off
means to start that thing
in this case they're starting the tour
which is a journey in which a person or
group visits several different places
in order to play or perform when joe
hears he's playing with durotea williams
he is very surprised so he expressed
this by saying
are you kidding me wow i would die a
happy man if i could perform with
dorothea williams
oh well this could be a lucky day
to die a happy man or woman is a phrase
that expresses extreme
happiness this is also used to literally
describe a person's status or condition
before they passed away
example he died a hero now let's go back
to hearing jamie foxx talk about this
once in a lifetime opportunity
that joe came across there's this big
gig that's coming up
a gig is a performance by a musician or
a group of musicians
example the beatles tribute band plays
several gigs every weekend
this is also an informal word used to
refer to a job especially one that
doesn't last for a long time
check out this example you're gonna be
great jared i'm just so excited
about this gig sir i mean what a what a
sweet gig
i've got a gig yeah you're saying gig a
lot oh so sorry i haven't worked in a
while
uh and he wants to go play for it and he
finally goes and auditions and
by play for it he means that he needs to
play well enough to convince dorothea or
the person in charge of selecting the
best musician
an audition is an occasion where an
actor or singer performs in front of a
judge
and if they're good enough they can get
a role in a play
movie etc or as in this case play an
instrument in a concert or gig
this is commonly used as a verb to
audition
uh he gets lost and from musicians or
anybody out there when you get lost in
your craft he's just in his thing
auditioning
no nerves he just went and they said wow
you're great you will have the gig
uh sorry i zoned out a little back there
and then has a accident that causes his
soul to
leave his body and almost go to the
great beyond
and so he is trying to get back into his
body and back to his life
the soul is defined by the part of a
person that is not physical
and that contains their character
thoughts and feelings
the great beyond is another term for
heaven the afterlife or a mystical place
where the soul of a person goes after
they die
so we still have one more clip to learn
with but i have a quick question
do you love disney movies like this one
then next you should check out this
playlist
where you will find a bunch of other
lessons with disney movies
that you will adore you can find that
clicking up here
or down in the description below
hey uh is this heaven
no is it h e double hockey
sticks
quiet coyote it's easy to get turned
around
this isn't the great beyond it's the
great before
the great before i play a character
named 22 who is a soul that's never been
born
because even though um the people in the
grape before have been trying to
convince her she's had a lot of mentors
trying to convince her that life is
great that she should go live on earth
she is very suspect of it she thinks it
sounds scary
painful difficult depressing smelly she
just doesn't want any part of it
she is uh joe's chance if he can kind of
convince her to go back then maybe he'll
get a chance to go back also
[Music]
uh hey uh is this heaven
no is it h e double hockey sticks
how
heaven or paradise is the opposite of
hell joe's soul is apparently so scared
at the possibility that where he wound
up
is hell that he doesn't even want to
utter it so he spells it
and in a rather childish way by double
hockey sticks
he means double l a hockey stick looks
like a capital l
hell how hell hello
[Music]
by quiet coyote she's gently asking
these young souls to be quiet
then she made this hand gesture because
it looks like a coyote closing its mouth
so as not to make any noise also notice
the pronunciation
coyote quiet coyote
it's easy to get turned around this
isn't the great beyond it's the great
before
the great before to get turned around
means to get lost
hey did we turn around somewhere i feel
like we're lost no i was just stalling
don't think about it
come on this way i play a character
named 22 who is a soul that's never been
born
uh because even though um the people in
the grape before have been trying to
convince her
there are some interesting features of
connected speech and how she says
have been trying to convince her have is
reduced to of
and connects to people people love the g
in trying isn't pronounced in fact two
gets reduced and morphs were trying
resulting in china
finally the h and her is dropped as well
and connects to convince
convince her she's had a lot of mentors
trying to convince her that life is
great that she should go live on earth
a mentor is an experienced person who
advises and helps a less experienced
person
you took away my future i'm simply
returning the favor
oh don't worry i'll be a good mentor
supportive encouraging
everything you want she uh is very
suspect of it she thinks it sounds scary
painful difficult depressing smelly she
just doesn't want any part of it
if you suspect something or are suspect
of something
you think there's something wrong with
it example
no one's expected anything was wrong
then if you say you don't want any part
of something
it means that you're unwilling to
participate in something or be involved
in any way okay so now you're going to
test
everything you learned today by watching
all the clips a final time
without subtitles and answering some
quiz questions
but before you go i wanted to remind you
that we make three lessons
every week to help you understand
natives and get
confident english fluency so the fastest
way to do this
is by not missing a single one so
remember to hit that subscribe button
and the bottom below if you haven't yet
[Music]
i play this jazz teacher who's sort of
stuck
uh happily stuck but still stuck in a
job where he's teaching jazz which is a
sort of a throwback of a trade
when it comes to musical trade he's
teaching jazz to his to his little
you know his little kids in in school
i'll be right back practice your scales
sorry to interrupt mr gardner you're
doing my ears a favor
hey not you though you're good he's not
what can i do for you principal arroyo i
wanted to deliver the good news
personally no more part-time for you
you're now our full-time van teacher
job security medical insurance pension
wow that's uh great welcome to the ms70
family joe
permanently thanks
but joe has always dreamed of being
something else
in his heart he's he's a musician at
heart and since he was very young joe
always wanted to be a professional jazz
musician you could say that
jazz music is the dream that joe's been
pursuing on nights and weekends his
entire adult life
[Music]
hello how you been mr g uh it's curly
lamont lamont baker hey curly hey good
to hear your voice man uh yeah listen uh
you can call me joe now curly i'm not
your teacher anymore okay mr gardner
hey look i'm the new drummer in the
dorothy williams quartet
and we're kicking off our tour with the
show at the half note tonight dorothea
williams are you kidding me are you
kidding me congratulations man
wow i would die a happy man
if i could perform with dorothea
williams oh well
this could be a lucky day
[Music]
there's this big gig that's coming up uh
and he wants to go play for it he
finally goes and auditions and
uh he gets lost and for musicians or
anybody out there when you get lost in
your craft he's just in his thing
auditioning
no nerves he just went and they said wow
you're great you
will have the gig and then has an
accident that causes his soul to leave
his body
and almost go to the great beyond and so
he
is trying to get back into his body and
back to his life
[Music]
hello how you been mr g uh it's curly
lamont lamont baker hey curly hey good
to hear your voice man
uh yeah listen uh you can call me joe
now curly i'm not your teacher anymore
oh okay mr gardner
hey look i'm the new drummer in the
dorothy williams quartet and we're
kicking off our tour with the show at
the half note tonight dorothea williams
are you kidding me oh you kidding me
congratulations man
wow i would die a happy man if i could
perform with dorothea williams
oh well this could be a lucky day
there's this big gig that's coming up
and he wants to go play for it and he
finally goes and auditions and
uh he gets lost and for musicians or
anybody out there when you get lost in
your craft he's just in his thing
auditioning
no nerves he just went and they said wow
you're great you will have the gig
and then has an accident that causes his
soul to
leave his body and almost go to the
great beyond
and so he is trying to get back into his
body and back to his life
hey uh is this heaven
no is it h e double hockey sticks
help help help help
quiet coyote it's easy to get turned
around
this isn't the great beyond it's the
great before
the great before i play a character
named 22 who is a soul that's never been
born
because even though the people in the
grape before have been trying to
convince her she's had a lot of mentors
trying to convince her that life is
great and she should go live on earth
she uh is very suspect of it she thinks
it sounds scary
painful difficult depressing smelly she
just doesn't want any part of it
she is joe's chance if he can kind of
convince her to go back then maybe he'll
get a chance to go back also
hey uh is this heaven
no is it h e double hockey sticks
help help
[Music]
it's easy to get turned around
this isn't the great beyond it's the
great before
the great before i play a character
named 22 who is a soul that's never been
born
because even though um the people in the
grape before have been trying to
convince her she's had a lot of mentors
trying to convince her that life is
great that she should go live on earth
she uh is very suspect of it she thinks
it sounds scary
painful difficult depressing smelly she
just doesn't want any part of it
she is uh joe's chance if he can kind of
convince her to go back then maybe he'll
get a chance to go back also
but the ultimate prize is the dragon no
one's
ever seen we call it the night
get down
this thing never steals food never shows
itself and
never misses no one has ever killed a
night fury
that's why i'm gonna be the first